Speaker 1: Donald Trump has been caught brutally
scamming his own followers again with a Herschel
Walker fundraising email where everything
is meant to look like the money is for Herschel
Walker.
But by default, only 10% of the donation actually
goes to Herschel Walker.
You have to see this.
Trump is a known scammer.
Trump scams his followers all the time.
What Trump's character is about is What can
you do for me now?
What money can you give me now?
Walker's campaign reports NBC News tells Republicans
to stop deceptive fundraising in the Georgia
runoff.
At least four committees, one of them associated
with Trump, have kept 90% of contributions
solicited for Herschel Walker.
I will explain to you how this works.
And NBC also explains it.
The campaign noticed the problem Saturday
when former President Donald Trump's Save
America sent out an email that asked prospective
donors to, quote, contribute any amount immediately
to the official Georgia runoff fundraising
goal and increase your impact by 1200 percent.
But if donors didn't see a link that said,
click here for details or to edit allocation,
they wouldn't have noticed 90% of the contributions
automatically go to the orange menace.
Mango.
Mussolini.
Donald Trump.
And only 10% go to Walker.
This is we could actually look at this.
This is a video put together by Jacob Rubashkin.
And what you will see as you click through
here is that you check that you want to contribute
a certain amount.
And then there is this link.
In this case, it was $250 that was click.
There's a link that says Click here for details
or to edit allocation.
If you just click the 250 or whatever amount
and then you look at the allocation, you will
see that, oh, in this case it's $1,000 of
the thousand dollar contribution.
900 was automatically allocated to go wait
a second to Donald Trump.
But this was a Herschel Walker fundraising
email.
And yet, unless you modify it, only 10% of
the donation goes to Herschel Walker.
NBC News reports that after this was highlighted,
Trump's committee changed it to a 5050 split,
a 5050 split.
This is not unique to Herschel Walker.
NBC News reports that at least originally
in some J.D.
Vance fundraising emails and Ted Bud fundraising
emails, it was initially also 9010.
Subsequently, some of those were changed.
It's the final grift or maybe not the real
final grift may be running for president again.
We just don't know.
We'll find out tonight.
Or maybe we won't find out tonight.
But this is what Donald Trump does.
And as I've told you before, Trump doesn't
like his followers.
Trump doesn't respect his followers.
We all know when we think about it, Donald
Trump was a rich kid from New York City who
spent his life insulating and isolating himself
from the very people who now are his supporters.
Sure, to some degree, he probably sees them
favorably to the extent that they support
him.
But we've seen very quickly, when there isn't
anything for them to vote for you for or for
them to donate to you for.
You flush them ten or 15 times.
Trump cares about his supporters.
If they might vote for him for something or
if they might donate money and he is now bilking
them even more.
Trump's plane has been repainted and refreshed
and renovated and fixed up so that now it
is flying him to rallies once again.
These people who support him should say, Wait
a second, we donated all this money.
He became president.
He didn't do any of the stuff he said he was
going to do.
It didn't do the health care plan.
I still have no health care.
I've terrible health care.
He didn't build the wall.
He didn't fix trade.
He didn't do any of those things.
Then he asked me for more money.
He lost in 2020.
And now he shows up making terrible endorsements
for people that end up losing in 2022 and
shows up in a new plane.
Did I pay for that plane?
Have I been scammed again by this guy?
But that is not the way they think it through.
That does not seem to occur to them.
And we will find out very, very soon whether
he still has the political cachet to continue
fundraising into 2023.
We have a fantastic bonus show for you today.
The Senate will act this week to codify same
sex marriage federally.
They say they have the votes, do they?
I think they do.
We'll talk about what this will mean.
Google is paying nearly $392 million to settle
a huge location tracking case.
I have some personal experience with this,
which I will share on today's bonus show.
Speaker 2: Oh, the bonus show where you want
to make money.
Everybody else that makes money to fund themselves
is bad.
Speaker 1: And lastly, even though Kevin McCarthy
wants to be the next speaker of the House,
if Republicans indeed take control of the
House of Representatives, some Republicans
are warning McCarthy, you don't have the votes
to be the speaker of the House.
Does he or doesn't he?
And if not, could he get them?
All of those stories and more on today's bonus
show.
Sign up.
Join pack mint.com.
Use the coupon.
Code 24 starts now to get a beautiful discount.
I'll
see
you next.